the rare hybrid of Princeton University
and cast of real-world alum from good
morning football Karl Brandt back here
on the Rich Eisen show how are you Kyle
rich did you know today this is the
hundred and fiftieth anniversary of the
first football game ever played
Princeton vs Rutgers today I did not
know that I won the game 6 to 4 and they
went on two years later have a lot of
great players to play for the Patriots
which is incredible
I was about to say how many left footed
punters did bela checks
great-great-great-great grandfather yes
I did play football Princeton and also
in many of our games that I played we
scored four points so it's a great
anniversary for all of us so is that was
that with that two safeties is that
really what it was I mean have we broken
down the back then because unless there
was a drastically different scoring
system six before the the final score
which I think was also the final score
of the Patriots Rams Super Bowl this
past year all come for a circle well I
think it was a big well I think the best
thing about it is that James K pulk had
Rutgers defense and special teams for
his fantasy team and he was lit up about
that result his starting time in
Jacksonville in 2009 - the rest in peace
at this point time you know it's amazing
when we were out there for the NFL
Network this past weekend in London Doug
Marrone told us the whole broadcast crew
you know what regardless of what happens
in the game he's gonna sleep on it he's
going to take the BAI we can come back
after the bye we can he waited basically
no time did that surprise ya a little
bit calm not front there
it didn't surprise me actually it I was
actually proud of him
because you think about this it was a
couple weeks ago rich they're handing
out 20,000 moustaches at Jacksonville it
was a cool thing it would've been very
easy to just say we got a thing going
here the fans like it the players
respond to it I think it was the prudent
decision to sit for a football man just
to say look I like the jean shorts as
much as the next guy but we got a guy
who gardner minshew has a statue no nick
foles has the statue let's put the guy
in who's actually won the Super Bowl
instead of going with some crazy fat I
was actually impressed that he did I
thought it was the prudent thing to do
so who do you have in that division what
do you think AFC South Carl hey you know
when luck retired we had this whole
debate and I said look I love Frank
Reich and I've learned quickly to never
give up on Frank Riga it's Frank
Wright's entire life is but not being
doubted and yet I said I gotta go with
the Shawn Watson I have to and I
remember you know Peter Straker my
cohort was just shaking his head and he
played that you know he played the whole
the Dick Vermeil press conference after
Trent Green got hurt and Dick Vermeil
saying we will rally behind Kurt Warner
and but we did this whole dramatic thing
about it we've seen it before
and I kind of wish I had gone with the
Colts that day because it felt good and
if I like to feel good story but
ultimately rich to answer your question
I just think the Shawn Watson is such a
rock star and I don't think he was great
in the playoffs last unit if you learn
from it I'm gonna go as good as the
stories the cold side I just go with the
talent with the Shawn you know having
seen him in person having personally
eyeballed him having personally seen his
eyeball that was still bloody before the
game in London it's tough to go away
from that but if pre-set is healthy
there's just something that screams in
me that maybe Frank Reich and the Colts
and certainly the Colts back in luck day
and in Manny's day just have the Texans
number in the fact that last year is we
all know Frank Reich went for it in some
overtime situation as opposed to playing
for the tie rather than going for he
went for the win instead of the tie and
getting of getting the loss other than
that I mean the the Colts have have done
the job including in the playoffs last
year but Watson is truly he's I guess
neck-and-neck with Russell Wilson and
Aaron Rodgers for the MVP who is your
MVP right now through Russ inaudible I
mean Russell Wilson made I think one bad
play this year knows it pick six to
Marcus Peters but other than that it's
fantastic
and I just I I think for a couple things
I think the MVP I get yet have the
numbers you got a win but also you you
gotta kind of give him that story like
if you got a story to run behind you
know last year of mahomes with the
sensation and the future of the league
and like I feel like Russ has now been
through it and he's he's outlasted the
LOB and the
CIM Butler and he's come clean on the
other side and he's playing his best
football with Pete Carroll like as I'm
saying it I can see this column being
written about Russell Wilson and I think
it's him and I think it's awesome I mean
I'm completely behind them and yet I
know it's just something special all
this - Shaun Watson you know that the
kick and the I thing it's it's
incredible because you know we hyped so
much last year mahomes about throwing a
no-look pass and really watching did his
own version of that because he wasn't
looking because his eyeball was almost
hanging out that's a more impressive
no-look pass in a way and I know for a
fact that you sat with him and you were
in the room with him and you've been
around a million - these guys did the
shot Watson not have I mean please
it really isn't it just it's a dream
come true for a franchise and you know I
recounted the story a little bit
yesterday just I I just I started off
the Watson chitchat with with the pre
broadcast meeting uh you know other
folks would start the you know we always
leave it to moot certainly with coaches
like so what do you think what do you
got you know that's sort of I said -
Watson among I got I got some questions
number one was is the first time a foot
ever got through your opening of her
face mask of your life yes he answered
and I'm like so then when you reached
for your helmet were you readjusting you
how many it was no actually I was
reaching in to touch my eyeball to see
if it was there I'm like really
legitimately thought and the NFL Films
move it you could see you could see like
his hand in there but you know obviously
though then there's Brady there's what
what happened with though with the
Ravens and and and the AFC in my mind is
still the the Patriots who was the team
to beat in your mind Kyle in the end the
NFC Collbran of good morning football
here on the Rich Eisen show what do you
got for me in the NFC right here you
know I think it's Power Rankings
Wednesday across the NFL across the
blogs all that and then you can shuffle
but you want and I'm just still going
back to New England I Adam I don't care
I've been through this too many times
I've sometimes the year I say well they
don't have it this year and their
offense isn't there and then I always
end up looking stupid so I have made it
a vow over the past three years
stays just just roll with no no matter
what I don't care what happens as long
as Brady and Belichick don't care that
I'm them goes out bill just James white
you to death we've seen it a million
times and I actually think like
yesterday or Sunday rather was
that chemo and every Patriots season the
oh they don't have it type loss and
they've been exposed to a year that they
lost of the Lions a year ago they lost I
met Patricia you really we can point
every season to the oh no they don't
have it loss I I just can't I can't get
off the train rich and I kind of want to
for entertainments sake on television
but I can't then the NFC you've got who
what do you think so far halfway through
it's really hard but I think the best
team in football is the Saints I do and
and I think you know I know this has
been said I think this is Sean Payton's
greatest campaign as a coach and
greatest and that's includes the
campaign in which the onside kicked in
the Super Bowl I just look at it as
they've been through the bad injury they
got that they've been through everything
they they have so many things going for
them and I still think they haven't
played their best football like I just
think so many years now under Sean
Payton you see teams tune out of coach
you see the message gets lost now maybe
that's what's happening in Atlanta right
now I think maybe that's what happened
with Mike McCarthy and Green Bay good
coaches you just tune them out I'm tired
of it I can't hear your speeches anymore
and the fact that Sean Payton this deep
into his stay in New Orleans is still
keeping it fresh and keeping them
determined it's amazing to me I mean
it's New Orleans I think it's the best
team in football so I take them the NFC
few more minutes left with Kyle Brent my
compadre from NFL Network yeah winning
football so you are a Bears guy anybody
watches this show knows that you
actually yeah were part of their
preseason broadcast team would you would
you turn the page on Mitchell true
Biscay right now Kyle Brent yeah I just
there's the premises ionica page it's
the last page in the book it's I gotta
say Rich's a guy grew up in Chicago this
has been one of the most bitterly
disappointing seasons of my life I think
the last time I was this disappointed as
a Chicago sports enthusiast he'd have to
look at the NLCS 2003 off the bat of
Luis Castillo the ball goes to left
field Moises Alou reaches for it and a
young gentleman from the north suburbs
with headphones on in a turtleneck
interferes with the Paul and the Steve
Bartman happened and then the Cubs
collapse and lose it that was the last
time I was as disappointed as I am in
this season and the problem with true
Biscay is
there's no recourse like the bears do
not have this young lady don't have a
Devlin Hodges or a Gardner Minshew or
any of these guys to say screw it let's
give it a shot they guy Mitch
they got chase Daniel who's not
happening they've already tried it and
that's it and the worst part of that is
okay so you're maybe you think you're
screwed this season there's no draft
picks like they spent them their draft
picks we're number 52 is a pass rusher
for the bears his name is Khalil they're
not going in this first round and
getting a pick so it's like not only
does Mitch not working they bet at all
they send Matt naggy we're going to give
you this young athletic quarterback from
the ACC and we think you can win with
them and they can it's just busted so
it's not just that it's not working I
don't see it fixed they're in a bad
marriage with no prenup and they just
got to ride it out and pay the piper
but that said there is potentially maybe
somebody older for this relationship
Kyle interim continue this analogy and
his name is Cameron and we all know
Cameron has been in a parade in in
Chicago in pop culture Fame this one
however will not be wearing a Red Wings
Jersey he's currently wearing a Panthers
jersey and it looks like he might be
available at age 31 nice and healthy
with a chip on his shoulder would you be
all for that if you can obviously work
out the cap ramifications what do you
think well I mean it would be worth it
riches to be showed up in that Gordie
Howe sweater I mean that would be
unbelievable oh my it's interesting
keeping up that analogy you would then
be getting out of this crazy marriage
and turn into a more mature woman an
older woman but man that woman has been
through a lot and she's got scars and
she's eccentric and she dressed the
strange and it changes the whole face of
your family and in this case that time
would be the Bears franchise I don't see
the macaques I don't see Ryan pace the
GM or Matt naggy saying we're gonna go
with Cam Newton because of course you
get seduced by cam but like has there
ever been a bigger buyer beware than Cam
Newton it's just it's like of course I'm
intoxicated by good cam but frankly I've
been waiting for good cam for about four
years and it's the
it's the foot and it's it's it sort of
feels like one of these if you can haul
it you can have it items on Craigslist
and I I love it but I'm very very scared
that if we pay can we bring them in and
it just doesn't have it anymore I so I
don't think that's the answer for the
Bears and that's a Bears fan like I
would rather have a completely fresh
start than a hand-me-down Cam Newton
well then at the risk of sounding even
creamier this analogy what about what
about somebody a little bit more steady
a little bit older but a little bit more
steady a lot of a very long-term
relationship that just didn't work out
this person was told it's not it's not
it's not me it's you
it's a redhead in an auntie dome what
would that be something that could be a
marriage for Chicago Carl you know it's
it's one of these things where it
doesn't blow you away okay but it's like
you know the Bears have been such a
crazy ride in their relationship and
it's one minute it's we're we're going
to Coachella and then we're gonna
Burning Man and up and down and we're
going to swingers parties it's been nuts
I can't go through this right and then
you have any dog says you know what I
just like to hang out and paint tiny
soldiers and watch that and secretaries
do and I think we can do that together
so the fact that they have these type of
players and the so-called genius and
naggy
this is where I met rich this is how
disappointing the season is this yes you
were suggesting to me would you like the
Bears to have Andy Dalton coming off a
winless team and guys never won a
playoff game and I'm thinking I think I
would like to date Andy Dalton let's do
it bring them in I actually would mmm
you know what by the way great Madam
Secretary poll I mean out of all the CBS
over that you can say she's president
insect president now Madam President hey
look if you want to go through pop
culture and television Benson started as
a butler wound up governor so I mean
there's been crazy different crazy
- resets right I and actually regretting
this you said you had your icebreaker
purchased on Watson I had one for you
and I didn't get to do it let me give
you this a I'm here in New York a New
York newspaper style blind item I want
to see if you can figure it out okay
here's our blind out of here okay yes
let's go yesterday
Kyle Brandt had the privilege to hang
out with a major movie star
who
was way back with Rich Eisen and is a
huge fan of the Rich Eisen show do you
know who it is
there's so many but I hung out with one
yesterday and I have a hint for you if
you need it I think I think I met I need
to go phone a friend or something like
that what do you got you can have your
hint is a movie star you said it could
be anybody okay you said him who miss
Turner it could be bacon it's another
this phantom I know with yesterday is a
huge fan of the Kansas City Chiefs and
goes way back with you and he could
possibly be an Avenger as well
oh it's Paul Rudd it's it's all right
good old road you got it all right and
was with Paul Rudd yesterday and I had a
text exchange and I mentioned some bees
oh I love rich I I go back with rich to
the first anchorman and all this he's
done so many things with you Paul Rudd
is the absolute best and he's so
thrilled about the Chiefs and I said you
couldn't say enough good things about
you Paul Rudd is a great human a great
human who just happens to be absurdly
famous and extremely popular and
successful and it's just a regular dude
love that guy
I love him and he's doing Ghostbusters
now he's doing another ant-man movie
he's the best he's absolutely bad the
whole cast is back and everything that's
really cool Karl Brandt I'd really love
and with you I love our chats and you
guys just killing it on Good Morning
football I tell you this every time and
I'll say it one more time on when the
NFL Network turned 16 yeah on on Monday
and for years we were wondering if there
would be another show on a daily basis
that could be the tentpole other
tentpole two NFL Total Access and then
along came good morning football with
you guys and you're crushing it killing
it and I really can't love watching it
more so thanks for the girl thank you so
much we get a little nuts sometimes we
refer to the show as total excess they
just popped up our Los Angeles broadcast
center crew just popped up B I guess
quartet your guys there yeah Halloween
costumes you went full bars that's very
nicely pasta fight it I had the Oakley's
I had the the Reebok pumps and I had a
blonde weave and I was just going
stone-cold
the whole time because anything less
would be uncivilized yeah well done Kyle
Brent thanks for the call brother we'll
chat soon I'll be flattered to be out
right thank you all right back at you
that's Karl Brandt at Kyle Brandt on
Twitter right here on the Rich Eisen
show Kay check out good morning football
every day on NFL Network at 7 a.m.
Eastern Time for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app